[Music]
hey guys cam here and welcome to reality
check
now The Witcher 3 is almost there and I
am really excited but it's also the
final part of the Geralt of Rivia
trilogy which makes me a bit sad you see
I spent a lot of time with this
character I think he's really great
and to be honest when he actually goes
I'm gonna be pretty gutted in fact I've
felt like this about a bunch of games
when they've eventually come to a close
Final Fantasy 7 Mass Effect
street-cleaning simulator so am I crazy
or emotionally fragile or both well
quite possibly but not because of that
in fact caring about the disappearance
or demise of a fictional character is
actually quite normal now in the past
this phenomenon has been dubbed the
Seinfeld effect named after the u.s.
sitcom which came to an end in 1998
what's the deal with that
however feeling sad following the
removal of a fictional character from
your life is not something exclusive to
TV or even games for that matter plus
there's some actual science behind why a
study carried out during the infamous
2007 2008 Hollywood writers strike
demonstrated that people experienced
distress when their favorite shows were
taken off air the researchers surveyed
403 college students aged 18 to 33 and
tasked them with answering questions
about their viewing habits reasons for
watching how important the shows were
and how close they felt to their
favorite characters after that they were
asked to describe their level of
distress as a result of their programs
being destructed by the strike now
unsurprisingly this stronger the
relationship the test subject felt with
the fictional characters the more
distressed they experienced men and
women were about equally distressed by
the cancellations although women in
general reported forging stronger
relationships than men did so how much
distress are we talking well the good
news is that on a scale of 1 to 5 1
being low 5 being high distress
the average distress reported was two or
three point five plus the researchers
concluded that all this was healthy and
normal and that it's something most
people do you see when we immerse
ourselves
fictional world we can often form these
parasocial relationships now these are
real relationships with a character or
characters who are not real now this may
seem strange but when you think about it
we frequently interact with fictional
versions of people we actually know even
in our most intimate personal
relationships we are often interacting
with a mental model of that person think
of a parent or a partner now how often
do you find yourself imagining their
current state of mind or how they might
respond to a situation even when they're
nowhere near you now that is not a far
cry from thinking in a similar way about
characters that don't even exist the
good news though is that these
parasocial relationships can actually be
positive as they enable us to explore
emotional and social realities without
some of the risks of real relationships
think about it our relationships with
fictional characters are one-sided in
terms of interaction that means we are
protected from things like social
rejection and also the physical danger
of threatening circumstances for example
that means we can form a relationship
with someone like Trevor from gta5
without the danger of him well you know
yeah that one final thing which is quite
interesting is that these parasocial
relationships we form with fictional
characters are almost identical to the
parasocial relationships regular viewers
of this show might have formed with well
me a bit weird isn't it so now we know
that feeling sad at the end of a
parasocial relationship is actually
quite normal which is good because this
is actually my final episode of reality
check yep after 99 episodes if you
include the wall F machine I was gonna
do number 100 on completion ISM but
that'll have to wait because I'm leaving
GameSpot and this show which I created
it's been a really tough decision but
it's time for me to move on thank you
all so much for watching over the last
few years because of you guys I've been
able to make what is ultimately a
science show on a videogames website you
guys are just the best it's been an
absolute
now if you want to continue our
parasocial relationship into the future
then make sure you go to Twitter and you
follow me at scam for as Rob fear not
though if you love reality check because
I have some good news following a short
hiatus Lucy will be taking the science
wheel and steering the good ship reality
check to new seas of video games science
and discovery see you all soon I hope
and make sure you come back to
Gainesville calm for more reality check
with Lucy in the future
good bye
[Music]